At the height of Paris Hilton's powers, Hollywood
greenlit a film called "The Hottie and theNottie."
By the time the movie had been filmed and
dumped into theaters, it was already a punchline.
It might just be one of the worst films
of all time. Hilton plays a "hottie"
who refuses to date until her "nottie"
friend also finds somebody. In theory,
the film was a comedy — but ultimately,
its parade of mean-spirited characters,
gross-out nonsense and offensive
plot points yielded negative laughs.
Richard Roeper was particularly scathing
in his assessment of the actors, saying,
"Nobody in this movie should
really have a career in movies."
Joel David Moore, who played the film's male
lead Nate Cooper, won the Razzie award for
worst onscreen couple along with Hilton. He
must be grateful that James Cameron didn't
feel like Roeper did about his acting abilities,
casting him as Dr. Norm Spellman in "Avatar."